2022 wie soll man dieses Jahr fassen die
Jahre zuvor hatten es doch schon in sich
als wir das Unerhörte erlebten das
Undenkbare aber dieses Jahr dieses 22
das hatte noch mal eine ganz andere
Wucht also die Wucht in der sich
Gewissheiten auflösen die Wucht in der
man Fehleinschätzungen erkennt die Wucht
der Ereignisse wir haben manchmal das
Gefühl in dieses Jahr
2022 hätten zehn heute schon ein Jahre
gepasst
das Jahr ist noch nicht alt als wir am
24 Februar Aufwachen ist die Welt eine
andere das hatte sich angekündigt es kam
von allen denkbaren Szenarien das
schlimmste
Russlands Überfall auf die Ukraine von
allen Seiten wir erleben eine
Zeitenwende ein untergegangenes
sowjet-reich will Putin wieder herbei
Bomben auslöschen was ihm im Weg steht
wir streben eine Demilitarisierung und
eine Entnazifizierung der Ukraine an
alles Lüge Putin Ziel von Anfang an auf
wehrlose Menschen
der Tod geht um in der Ukraine
er trägt das Z als Zeichen für
spezialoperation bösartiger Zynismus
Propaganda fürs eigene Volk das an
Heldentaten glauben soll Geschosse
gutheißen gerichtet auf Zivilisten und
Reaktoren Angst als Druckmittel
für fake-verhandlungen
trotz vereinbarter Waffenruhe Treffen in
der Hafenstadt Mariupol heute Bomben
eine Entbindungsklinik schwangere Frauen
als Ziel
friedliche Vororte sind Massengräber die
Bevölkerung zahlt den Preis für
Russlands früher Misserfolge
sie gehen rein wenn ihnen ein Haus
gefällt erschießen alle sie schmeißen
die Leichen raus verbrennen sie und dann
übernachten Sie dort putin wird Soldaten
die hier mordeten später auszeichnen und
die Bilder aus Butcher als Inszenierung
verwöhnen
Reportagen aus der Apokalypse
für mich ist Butcher in diesem Krieg ein
Schlüsselmoment gewesen weil wir haben
da zum ersten Mal gesehen mit welcher
hemmungslosen aber gleichzeitig auch
systematischen Brutalität Russland Krieg
gegen die ukrainische Zivilbevölkerung
führt das war für mich ein Moment wo ich
gesehen habe das ist ein
Zivilisationsbruch der heute mitten in
Europa stattfindet
vor dem fast ein Viertel der
ukrainischen Bevölkerung flieht zu den
Grenzen nach Westen und weiter wo
überwältigende Hilfsbereitschaft wartet
Momente der Menschlichkeit so wertvoll
im Wahnsinn dieses Krieges
Zusammenhalt macht stärker dazu gehört
ein Präsident der nicht müde wird zu
seinem Volk zu sprechen eines seiner
ersten Videos mit samtkabinett wohl sein
wichtigstes wir sind alle hier das
Militär ist hier die Bürger sind hier
wir verteidigen unsere Unabhängigkeit
unser Land der Präsident omnipräsent
jedes Bild wohl durchdacht jedes Wort
wirkt auch im ZDF heute journal
wir brauchen von Kanzler Scholz die
Sicherheit dass Deutschland die Ukraine
unterstützt er und seine Regierung
müssen sich entscheiden soll Deutschland
schwere Waffen liefern Panzerhaubitzen
Schützenpanzer bloß nicht direkt besser
im Ringtausch lange Diskussionen darüber
die 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr
waren rasch beschlossen hier muss warten
wir kämpfen nicht für sich selbst wir
kämpfen für alle demokratische Welt
einen Vorteil haben die Verteidiger sie
sehen im Internet wohin sie schießen
müssen private Satelliten hatten Putins
Generäle wohl übersehen wer nicht
abgeschossen wird bleibt liegen
Blitzkrieg ohne Benzin
wochenlang verteidigt eine kleine Gruppe
Kämpfer erfolgreich das Stahlwerk in
Mario Paul die Ukraine versenkt das
Flaggschiff der russischen
Schwarzmeerflotte sprengt die
grimm-brücke erobert Gebiete zurück
was mich auch immer wieder beeindruckt
hat war dieses dieser durchhalte Wille
der durchhalte Wille der Ukraine ist
enorm und bündelt sich in einem Satz
wir lachen damit wir nicht weinen müssen
Weinen mussten wir mit Lydia aus irpin
ich weine nicht wegen diesem Desaster
ich weine wegen unserer kraftvollen und
schönen jungen
die Geld gesammelt hat
die lidias Haus wieder aufbaut die Trost
spendet
mit unserer Jugend muss man sich vor
nichts fürchten nicht vor Krieg oder
irgendeiner Katastrophe von nichts sie
werden alles aufräumen wieder aufbauen
und alles wird wieder schön werden und
während sie an einem Ort tapfer aufbauen
und gehen woanders wieder geschossen
nieder Zermürbungskrieg Mord mit allen
Mitteln
Energie macht der pressbar auch uns das
Land Deutschland in diesem Jahr und das
ist auch ohne Gas aus Russland geht aber
es geht nicht gut Putin dreht die
Pipelines zu wir die Heizung Stück für
Stück Gerät die Regierung unter Druck
womit sollen wir heizen wie viel ist
überhaupt noch da und wie soll das
bezahlen
Deutschland Start auf gasfüllstände
unter Energieminister spricht Klartext
Gas ist von nun an ein knappes Gut
Geduld auch denn die ohnehin gewaltige
Belastung befeuert eine eben solche
Inflation es brodelt im Volk was tun
das ist ja ein Doppelpunkt doppelbums
200 Milliarden der Bund zahlt mit bei
Gas und Strom vom Tankrabatt stecken
sich die Ölkonzerne ordentlich was ein
und zahlen dafür selbst einen hohen
Preis die übergewinnsteuer kommt
der Wumms weckt Begehrlichkeiten
Energiespar Lektion wenn da jemand sagt
ich helfe nur wenn ich noch mal 50 Euro
Kriege würde ich sagen die kriegst du
nicht Alter
die Grünen kriegen auch was nicht
Ausstieg aus Kohle und Atom jedenfalls
nicht jetzt dafür Krach mit den
Umweltverbänden die genau das fordern
Nachfrage also keine klare Ablehnung im
Moment ist ja die Parteilinie
nein nein nein nein
ich finde das Land hat gut reagiert es
gab keine geldwesten Proteste und am
Ende ist auch die Regierung über ihren
eigenen Schatten gesprungen und hat
gegen ihre eigenen Vorsätze die Sie zu
Beginn des Jahres hatte gehandelt
doppelwumms unter der Ostsee beide North
Stream pipelins durchlöchert ein
Whirlpool aus Methan der Todesstoß für
Gas aus Russland auch zeitenwände
dem Klima sind krisenwurst auch 2022
Feuer und Wasser
Naturkatastrophen Folgen stur den Regeln
der Physik Folgen der Erderwärmung
die Hoffnung sie in den Griff zu
bekommen schwindet auch in diesem Jahr
während die Wut darüber wächst und die
Verzweiflung und hier sind alle Häuser
im Arsch
dann kann auch die Kunst zum Teufel
gehen die radikale Logik der klimakleber
sie verlangen radikale Klimarettung
Proben eine völlig neue Form des zivilen
Ungehorsams die Aufmerksamkeit ist Ihnen
sicher doch sie verlieren was Sie für
Ihr Anliegen brauchen
Sympathie
die Probleme sind real und viel
radikaler in Europa fällt monatelang
kein Regen der Dürre Monitor sieht
dunkelrot und die Feuerwehr weiß gar
nicht wo Sie anfangen soll mehr Warnung
geht nicht
mehr Party auch nicht zu Beginn dieses
Jahres feiern die Briten erst Geburtstag
dann Thron Jubiläum ihrer Queen in Amt
und Alter hochbetagt eine Legende eine
vollendete
als die Familie zu ihr nach Schottland
eilt hält das Land den Atem an
und sieht zwei Stille Diener eine knappe
Notiz zum Zaun von Buckingham Palace
tragen
die Königin ist tot
eine gigantin geht ihr Empire war schon
lange vor ihr gegangen und lebt wieder
auf im Angesicht des Todes Glanz und
Gloria auch in Vollendung
lebe wohl zu sagen tut weh und trotzdem
tut es gut überhaupt trauern zu können
viele die hier um die Queen weinten
holten auch die Trauer um ihre Corona
Toten nach ein letztes Mal ist Elisabeth
II Fels und Anker ihres Volkes
was ich beeindruckend fand war dass
viele Leute traurig waren das ist aber
auch ein Fest war es war ein Fest des
Lebens der Queen das war das Königreich
das alle liebten das Königreich der
Queen und es war wie das bessere
Großbritannien das war so ein Gefühl was
ich sehr stark empfunden habe dass sie
für das Stand was die Briten eigentlich
sein wollen und jetzt nicht mehr sind
[Musik]
starb auch im September meine Frau von
vielen in Iran voller Träume und
Hoffnung in einer Realität die das nicht
vorsieht nicht für Frauen sie leiden sie
sterben still der Stille folgt der
Aufschrei Folgen Hymnen der Hoffnung
für das Leben für die Freiheit
verbrennen Irans Frauen ihr Kopftuch
riskieren ihr Leben weil sie längst
keins mehr haben weil eine von ihnen
mach so Amini die Nacht im
Polizeigewahrsam nicht überlebt
hergebracht wegen eines Kopftuchs
weggebracht im Koma
Iran brennt lichterloh
und diese Botschaft kommt an in diesen
Tagen
diese auch
sie stehen für Veränderung Courage es
beginnt etwas Großes
die Frauen die im Iran auf die Straße
gehen die haben unser aller Hochachtung
verdient und meine haben sie auf jeden
Fall ich finde das bemerkenswert ich
finde das mutig und es zeigt vor allem
wie verzweifelt diese Menschen sind
nicht nur die Frauen auch die Männer ich
glaube inzwischen haben auch die Männer
verstanden dass auch ihre Freiheit
gleichermaßen mit der Freiheit der
Frauen einhergeht und deswegen ist das
so wichtig
und deswegen haben sie einander
untergehakt der Todesstrafe und den
Mulas zum Trotz Frauen und Männer
Heldinnen und Helden auch zeitenwände
2022 und wir sagen tschüss Corona Masken
runter Inzidenzen rauf wir testen
weniger und Vertrauen auf Impfungen
Corona bleibt tödlich verschont aber die
Kliniken andere Erreger nicht
Deutschland liegt flach und wartet auf
Medizin doch die ist selbst schwer krank
kaputt gespart 2022 gab es für die
Fallpauschale die Quittung
Party ja aber ein Partyjahr wurde es
nicht zu viel Veranstaltungen abgesagt
2022 ging echt an die Substanz
ihr könnt auch wirklich kotzen und
heulen gleichzeitig da sagten auch
Gastwirte Reisende und wer sonst noch
wartete etwa auf Handwerker oder
Halbleiter
immer wenn ich mit unseren
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauern Rede kommt
eigentlich ein Satz jedes Mal nämlich
bitte bringt auch mal Nachrichten die
ein bisschen Hoffnung machen es gab
diese Nachrichten zum Glück die
Redakteurinnen und Redakteure das heute
Journals haben ein paar eingesammelt
keinesfalls abschließend oder auf jeden
Fall sehr subjektiv
mein positiven Moment in diesem Jahr war
die Goldmedaille von Niklas Kaul in zehn
Kampf bei der Europameisterschaft die
Bundesregierung verdoppelt Mittel zum
Kampf gegen den Hunger das 9 euro-ticket
die NASA hat es geschafft einen
Asteroiden aus der Umlaufbahn zu drängen
dass wir ein angepassten Corona
Impfstoff haben Böhmermann liegt die
nsu-akten zum Glück wurden die
affenbrocken kein zweites Corona
gewinnt den Eurovision Song Contest
Nobelpreis ärzte dürfen über
Abtreibungen informieren
Taylor Swift besetzt Platz 1 bis 10 der
amerikanischen Charts überall auf der
Welt stehen Menschen für ihre Rechte ein
riskieren alles kämpfen für Demokratie
und das hat viel Gutes und macht
Hoffnung für das nächste Jahr das
hoffentlich ein friedlicheres wird und
dass wir wieder sehr genau im Blick
haben werden für Sie